you les gens c'est squeeze c'était un
franck c'est fabien olicard vous avez
deux vidéos en une maintenant que le
plan qui est passé on va parler de ça
alors oui cette semaine vous avez vu
c'est un plus petit casse tête que la
pandora box deux fois j'en ferai des
plus simples et deux fois des plus
compliquées celui ci je pressens qui va
me faire galéré parce qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup d'actions possibles et en
général quand il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'actions possibles c'est vraiment pas
bon signe mais il ya une chose qui est
sûre c'est que ça ça ne sert à rien j'ai
demandé et en fait c'est juste vraiment
pour entrer un porte-clés donc voilà
faut pas que je m'en sers pour faire
quoi que ce soit donc le but du jeu
c'est simplement d'enlever simplement
l'étoile du serpent parce que c'est un
serpent qui se mord la queue
et ensuite comme dans tout bon casse
tête si tu enlèves tu dois être capable
de remettre après de simples jets quoi
je détaille avec vous - j'ai quatre
branches identique
c'est un élément et deux plus petites
il y en a une de chaque côté bon alors
je vais essayer de trucs classiques qui
ne va servir à rien mais là c'est à dire
qu'en fait tu essaies d'en passer une
était obligé de faire une rotation est
en fait elle garde toujours ah oui
d'accord en fait c'est tellement relou
l'esa dans les casses têtes outil dit ah
ouais mais elles n'ont en fait il ya un
permanence les deux petites branches qui
se met naturellement une de chaque côté
ou alors on sent très aimé a oui
d'accord ok je peux regarder ça comme ça
voilà c'est ça si je les oublie l
ça passe au centre et y en a un de
chaque côté donc c'est forcément sur une
rotation et j'imagine que la forme du
serpent tu n'es pas un cercle parfait du
tout d'ailleurs
en fait c'est chaud parce que j'ai
l'impression de faire des gestes
différents mais à butten tailor made et
je crois qu'il se passe quelque chose
mon gars là en vrai j'ai fait un truc là
non en fait ouais d'accord comme tout
est symétrique je peux avoir
l'impression de faire un truc
et au final je me retrouve toujours le
même config parce que vous aviez vu
qu'en ce moment chaud des vidéos sur
instagram
sinon vous pouvez cliquer juste au
dessus de moi pendant que moi je cherche
je comprends pas quand ça c'est qu'il ya
si peu de monde sur un stop bah ça c'est
un autre casse tête qui va falloir que
je raisonne par jour dont on peut être
suivies par 750 mille personnes sur
youtube et par si peu de monde sur un
nom j'ai tellement fait un truc mais non
mais attends j'ai dit que les quatre
branches est la même ah oui si au
nominal mais pas dans son sac
donc je pense qu'il faut aller chercher
une rotation en coin et peut-être faire
une rotation dans le mouvement
donc je sais pas si je suis très clair
mais je me dis si je tourne en partant
d'un coin et en allant vers l'autre coin
est-ce que là ya pas un truc un coup à
faire et
c'était pas mal dans l'idée mais ça n'a
strictement rien donné
après scarlett parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'en forçant je pourrais y
arriver
déjà je pense que c'est faux et je pense
surtout que il n'ya pas un casse tête au
monde qui existe avec comme solution tu
dois forcer ça donne envie quand même
deux tabliers fort si j'avais des deux
petits du même côté jeux sortis à vous
alors vous savez j'ai commencé cette
vidéo avec loïc il ya deux jours quel
moment donné il est parti depuis noël
loïc situé là le bouger c'est top c'est
notre scientifique du fiction je sais
que tu cherches économie à dire ou pas
mais en attendant ce temps là j'ai
résolu un casse-tête bourne défaire la
casse tête c'est une chose me refaire
ses terres le remettre c'est la manière
de prouver qu'on a bien compris comment
ça marche et je vais être honnête avec
vous j'ai essayé des rotations en
translation comme ça tout en parlant
pour rien dire et un moment donné j'ai
vu que ça marche et que je l'avait
enlevée josé paccaud bon ok en tout cas
ça a été bien mon système de rotation
pour le m il est en plus il est est ce
que c'était parce qu'au départ que tu le
lendemain il a l'air hyper fragile du
genre tu vas faire ça ça va tomber et
tellement pas quand ça ça le lan pour la
partie métallique ali elle doit entourer
à moitié les quatre branches identique
donc si je veux reproduire ça il faut
déjà que je sois exactement comme ça
donc là deux grandes branches d'un côté
de l'autre
sauf qu'il y en a un des deux petits qui
devrait de l'autre côté du coup si je
rentre un petit
si je rentre un petit un grand ça veut
dire qu'il me reste un grand à rentrer
merci de jamais isolé cette phrase de ce
trio voyez ça c'est vraiment typique du
gac a réussi son casse tête sans trop
savoir comment il l'avait fait parce
qu'il serait drôle c'est que vous ayez
le même casse-tête et que vous soyez en
train de le résoudre en toc points on
pourrait être un batteur est sûr que
dans le nombre y en a qui réussit à
l'abandon en postulat vous vous êtes en
vacances vous êtes en planète et moi
j'étais en train de me presser si ça se
trouve vous êtes en train de me regarder
à la plage peut-être même en lisant mon
deuxième tome qui a dit placement de
produits à cette phrase c'est impossible
ah oui d'accord ok si c'est bon tu viens
de comprendre
ok donc si je ne comprends que c'est à
dire que je suis capable de le remettre
[Musique]
c'est ça j'annonce officiellement que ce
casse-tête est résolu évidemment vous
allez trouver le lien de ce casse-tête
dans la description et puis tout l'été
ce sera un casse tête par semaine et
après tu peut activer la cloche mais il
ya aussi des vidéos en plus peut-être en
bonus peut-être pas tu peux tu abonnés à
mon instagram un monde dailymotion ou
les vidéos sont en avance mais surtout
qui n'entend que son de ma voix sur la
chaîne varech tu ta bonne à cette chaîne
youtube s'est fait saisir
parce que les bonnes vacances aux
nouveaux livrets sorties la troupe 5 à
10 heures en fait
rendez-vous à l'olympia ciao